the amount of external stimuli that
increases exponentially through
technology and through social networks
affects our pursuit of meaning when
we're interconnected with so many agents
around the world we feel that we want
everything even if we don't really
possess the capacity to imagine what
everything would feel like I guess
that's why everyone enjoys the idea of
parallel universes we want so many
things that only multiple interconnected
versions of ourselves can offer that
luxury in this weird landscape most of
us fail to recognize one Paramount
detail about human nature we're quite
valuable creatures meaning that we are
capable of making mistakes or being
wrong and it is this valuability that we
need to reduce in order to make our
experience more tolerable and eventually
come up with a proper meaning for our
lives in the current point in time two
seem to be the most relevant rules we
need to follow in order to reduce
valuability to pick our battles wisely
and to embrace slowness